[Musique]
tous les dimanches à versaill nous avons
décidé de faire un d'organiser un
rassemblement en soutien aux otages et à
leur famillees pour que personne ne les
oublie alors nous savons bien sûr que
nos rassemblements ne seront pas
décisifs dans la libération des otages
mais ce que nous souhaitons c'est que un
maximum de gens pensent à eux et se
tiennent au côté de leur famille pour
montrer que nous n'oublions
pas tout le monde peut venir et faites
le savoir et diffusez-le autour de vous
nous vous attendons tous les dimanches
devant la mairie de Versailles à l'angle
de l'avenue de Paris et de l'avenue du
Général de Gaulle de 11h30 à 12
[Musique]
he30